[Music]
hi everyone it's joanna here time sure
flies and without knowing it another
year is about to end and we're headed
towards another new year
so as the year comes to a close a lot of
us may already be starting to plan our
new year's resolutions or some of us
might still be trying to complete the
current one before the year ends no
matter what staying fit and healthy has
always been one of the main new year's
resolutions for most people this is the
time where we would rip out our planner
and start planning our workout regime
and meal plans to start the year strong
it's great to have a fitness resolution
however we know that the real challenge
is to stick to our resolution studies
have shown that 80 of people failed in
adhering in their new year's resolution
by the end of january i don't want you
to be the 80
i want you to be the 20 who not only
succeed but stick to it in many years to
come in this video i'll be sharing with
you the 7 ways to lose weight and keep
it off for good
one of the first mistakes most people
tend to make when it comes to starting a
weight loss journey is to have the more
the better mindset they would
immediately commit to working out five
to seven days a week and drastically
changing their diet it is good that
you're taking steps and setting goals
towards improving your health and
fitness however your body and mind needs
time to gradually adjust into an active
and healthier lifestyle so instead of
beating yourself up when you've missed a
workout session or failed to meal prep
start off easy and focus on small
achievable goals for example focus your
goal into staying physically active
throughout the day by walking more
taking the stairs instead of the lift or
escalator standing up and moving around
the office whilst at work or even doing
house chores those incidental activities
will benefit your health in the long
term or even simple healthy habits such
as drinking two to three liters of water
a day and getting between 6 to 8 hours
of sleep so start off by applying those
simple habits and build on that
most of the time people fail because
they start off by setting goals which
are unrealistic and too overwhelming for
instance i want to lose 20 kilos in 3
months or i want to meal prep every
single meal and workout 7 days a week
before setting your goals it is very
important that you understand your
lifestyle and daily commitments
do you have the time to hit the gym
every day is that realistic have you
eaten takeaways every single day and do
you think you'll be able to change that
and cook every single meals for yourself
it is important that you have an honest
and open conversation with yourself
before setting your goals
don't set unrealistic expectations
because by doing that you're only
setting yourself up for failure you
would get really frustrated when you
fail to show up for a workout session or
you failed to meal prep so be honest and
set realistic and achievable goals
because this will lead you to success
perhaps you're only able to commit three
to four days to exercising that's
absolutely fine if you achieve more days
then well done and you can slowly
increase your expectations perhaps you
can only prep one meal a day and choose
healthier options when you eat out a
realistic weight loss goal is two to
four kilos a month so if your goal is to
lose 20 kilos let's make it a six to
nine month goal so i've created a video
on how to design a workout plan which
you can watch and set your own workout
plan
nutrition is extremely crucial when it
comes to weight loss i'm sure you have
heard this saying 80 food 20 exercise
however hopping on to a diet fat as part
of your new year's weight loss
resolution may only lead to more yo-yo
dieting and this is not sustainable
long-term if there is one thing you can
do right now is to ditch the word
dieting when we think of dieting it is
often associated to restriction
short-term and unsustainable regimes
most people who have the dieting mindset
tend to gain more weight over time let
me know in the comments below if you
have dieted before
so ditch dieting and change that to
healthy eating instead focus on
nourishing your body instead of
depriving it and be mindful of your
eating habits watch this video right
here and learn how you can lose weight
without eating less most of the time we
tend to overeat because we're not aware
of our hunger and appetite we eat until
we're absolutely stuffed and sometimes
we're not even aware of the food we've
eaten if i were to ask you right now to
think back of all the meals and snacks
you have eaten today
can you list them down how did you feel
while eating were you truly hungry how
did you feel afterwards satisfied or
guilty i've also filmed a video on the 8
types of hunger which you can watch and
learn more about your own eating habits
once you're able to eat and stop when
your body feels about 80 full you'll
realize that eating healthily and
mindfully is not that difficult
and this habit will help you to keep
your weight off for good and maintain a
healthy weight for life
our goal primarily is to become fitter
healthier and happier person from the
inside and out
what if i told you that shedding those
ponds can be as easy as engaging in a
little spring cleaning well it's true
the new year is a good time to spring
clean and organize your pantry this is a
perfect opportunity to create a clean
slate of food supply at home so remove
all processed and junk food from your
home that aren't helping you to lose
weight replace them with fresh natural
food if you store junk food at home
chances are you will eat them if you
stock up on fresh natural food similarly
you are more likely to eat them i mean
just think about it if you have cookies
out on your kitchen counter chances are
you will snack on them
instead replace them with healthier
snacks such as nuts and seeds so that
you will reach for healthier options i
truly believe that weight loss starts
from home and the simple tricks of
cleaning out and organizing your pantry
can help you towards a healthy lifestyle
not just for you but for your family as
well
weight loss and health is not just about
the numbers on the scale of course it's
important to weigh yourself to know if
you're on track with the amount you need
to lose saying that however i don't want
you to be obsessed overweight yourself
every single day and determine your
success solely based on the number on
the skill
only weigh yourself once a week and know
that your progress is not solely
determined by the number on the scale if
you're wondering why the number of the
skill isn't moving but you feel that
your clothes fit better and that you
look slimmer that's because you have
increased in muscle mass and reduced in
body fat
one pound of muscle mass is more dense
than one pound of fat so even if your
weight remains the same you will look
more firm and toned beyond that staying
active and eating well will also
contribute to your overall health such
as feeling happier having more energy
better sleep and lower stress levels to
me those are extremely important factors
in staying fit and healthy
i truly believe that having a support
system can be that extra support and
motivation we need to stay on track and
achieve our goals when you're able to
share your goals and progress with
like-minded people it will give you a
sense of accountability they will also
be able to offer you support and
motivation when things get tough it can
be either a workout partner a family
member who cheers you on or even a
personal trainer if you do need help
getting started as well as to stay
accounted for your goals you may try out
our own fitness app called feel and get
access to a wide variety of workout
programs meal plans and even mindset
videos to guide you through
links and special discount is in the
description box below so be sure to
check it out
most people who jump off their weight
loss resolution bandwagon do so because
they don't see results within the first
four weeks of adapting to change
we need to remember that change takes
time and patience doing that by adapting
to healthy lifestyle practices such as
exercising and eating well you're
already setting yourself towards success
but the key word here is adaptation
allow your body to adapt so you got to
work towards achieving what you want
every single day forget about going on
the fast lane and because it is a
journey there will be lots of ups and
downs i can tell you right now that it
won't be a smooth journey and it won't
be easy you'll have this where you feel
extremely motivated and out of the
sudden you might fall back into your old
habits of [ __ ] eating again
if you can foresee this you can better
prepare yourself for when it happens and
overcome it with certain strategies
remember do not turn relapses or
temporary failures into meltdowns or
excuses for giving up instead
acknowledge the mistake look at ways on
how you can better manage it when it
happens and recommit to the path again
all right guys time to put your best
foot forward and kick start this new
year strong let me know what's your
fitness goal in the comments below and
how you plan on achieving that if you
enjoyed this video then do give this
video a thumbs up and do hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet done
it and also let me know in the comments
below what videos do you want more of
and i will see you in my next video
all the best and happy new year